[Musica]
per me è un piacere soprattutto essere
qui a partecipare ad un evento
condotto e gestito dagli studenti questo
è l'essenza di quello che anche noi
facciamo
quotidianamente e per me è veramente un
vero piacere sono qui a rappresentare in
senso lato la medicina in particolare
e là sotto specializzazione della
neurochirurgia e questo in un certo
senso fa parte del tema del tema del
nostro nel nostro incontro uncovered e
appunto per scoprire alcuni aspetti
della nostra attività che forse non sono
noti a tutti chi magari per sfociare in
quella che a me piace dire essere uno
dei risultati della tecnologia avanzata
che è quella della
della
aumenti al reality della realtà
aumentata quindi un po diciamo declinare
il così è se vi pare
così è aumentato se vi pare e per questo
volevo parlarvi un po della nostra
specialità alla neurochirurgia perché
perché la neurochirurgia è una
specialità complessa che ha bisogno il
progresso tecnologico proprio perché noi
siamo abituati a lavorare gli spazi
molto ristretti in prossimità con
strutture
neurovascolari
anatomiche
fragili
sì quindi tutto l'aiuto che possiamo
ottenere dal dall apporto tecnologico
fondamentale ma è anche una specialità
che si prende cura di pazienti che hanno
patologie che possono influenzare
significativamente
quelle funzioni che ci rendono
particolarmente
ripartire particolarmente diversi e
superiori funzioni cognitive che
funzioni di relazione e questo questo
bilancio tra quello che è il nostro
scopo di essere aggressivi nei confronti
della patologia ma rispettosi della
funzione e delle funzioni più alte e non
soltanto quelle fisiche ma quelle
cognitive di relazione
esattamente l'essenza di quello che
facciamo come possiamo declinare il
discorso del
avanzamento tecnologia ho cercato di
fare un piccolo riassunto ovviamente vi
invito a partecipare con me venire con
me brevemente né in quello che io
considero il nostro
parco biotecnologico che la nostra sala
operatoria cercando di essere in molto
modesto se vogliamo anche nella nella
grafica delle rappresentazioni delle
immagini che vadano prese a
mostrarvi comunque avanzamento
tecnologico integrazione multimodale
sono fondamentali stati progressi
recenti nella neurochirurgia perché
perché aiutano una ridotta invasività e
sempre importante quello che normalmente
si dice il minimale invece fa è una
maggiore precisione
una riduzione dei tempi è importante
anche nel panorama quotidiano e attuale
è quello della riduzione dei tempi e
alla fin fine i risultati migliori per
il paziente che il nostro alla nostra
missione principale
come lo posso rappresentare
alcuni aspetti dell'avanzamento
tecnologico
forse il modo più eloquente anche meno
chiamiamolo grafico o
diciamo impressionante dal punto di
vista di certe immagini sala operatoria
è proprio la
e progresso delle immagini sono immagini
non soltanto che fanno vedere gli
aspetti anatomici nel nostro cervello ma
anche gli aspetti funzionali
queste sono immagini che dimostrano una
risonanza che vi fanno vedere una
risonanza magnetica funzionale nelle tue
immagini superiori e qui vediamo la
lesione che noi andremo a
a trattare che in prossimità con queste
e queste zone colorate che altro non
sono che le zone
del cervello
deputate alla funzione della parola è la
funzione motoria e la funzione visiva
quelle più indietro queste queste sono
cose fondamentali perché ci consentano
veramente di
navigare nel momento in cui andiamo a
trattare la patologia interessata
ovviamente cercando di evitare queste
queste zone nella nella
nell'immagine sottostante che sembra più
un'opera artistica non forse della
qualità della dell'artista che mi ha
preceduto però fanno vedere in sostanza
i fascicoli
sottostanti alle aree corticali quelli
che mettono in comunicazione le diverse
aree cerebrali questo è importantissimo
perché se è vero che la partita si gioca
evitando le zone eloquenti è anche
altrettanto vero che noi dobbiamo essere
sempre
convinti e
avere un'idea dettagliata di quelle che
sono le la rado mia dei fascicoli di
conduzione questo con la tecnica estate
si può fare con la tecnica particolare
che si chiama dpa il che vuol dire di
fusion per i magi che sfrutta
il movimento delle molecole di acqua
lungo e le fibre nervose e questo
movimento da dei segnali particolari che
vengono colti e quindi si possano
mappare anche i fascicoli sottostanti
alla corteccia cerebrale questo dal
punto di vista pratico come
ricostruzione ci consente come in queste
immagini di vedere appunto la lesione
circondata da determinati fascicoli
questo è un fascicolo al 4
importantissimo per quanto riguarda la
condizione tra i diversi centri della
parola e quindi a lui ci consente di
sapere esattamente come sono coinvolti
se sono coinvolti come preservare
questi stessi fascicoli quindi vedete
qui anche le immagini
del
centro della parola questo al centro
della mobilità in questo centro della
della visione in un cervello umano
nell'emisfero di sinistra
eccolo appunto queste immagini questo
possiamo poi lavorare nella preparazione
decidendo qual è la traiettoria migliore
per arrivare determinate lesioni proprio
navigando questi fascicoli come faccio
vedere in questa immagine se queste
immagini che riassume appunto in grigio
la patologia è la distanza e l'anatomia
e dei questi fascicoli
sottocorticali
ma e non si limita soltanto
all'avanzamento delle immagini come ho
detto come accennato dobbiamo essere in
grado anche di navigare con tutte le
informazioni che abbiamo queste
situazioni e finley i sistemi di
navigazione che stati messi appunto
all'inizio degli anni 90 che adesso
hanno un livello di sofisticazione
significativo ci consentono veramente di
navigare in qualsiasi momento come sia
col gps in automobile e sapere a che
distanza siamo da determinate strutture
qual è la traiettoria migliore e questo
è un importanza enorme qui vedete
appunto alle immagini di una lesione
che è in prossimità con strutture
vascolari molto importanti e quindi la
ricostruzione tridimensionale di questo
ci consente poi durante l'intervento di
sapere che distanza siamo da quelle
strutture che è obbligo
obbligatoriamente dobbiamo preservare
quali altri avanzamenti sono stati
particolarmente
significativi nella mia nella vostra
specialità il microscopio l'endoscopio e
dello scoppio che sono essenzialmente
declinazioni di quella spinta verso
l'immagine in dettaglio con
un'appropriata illuminazione che è
fondamentale quando si lavora in aria
recondite del cervello umano quindi
questi sono stati altri strumenti che
fanno parte appunto del nostro parco
biotecnologico in sala operatoria che
sono fondamentali per consentirci
interventi in sicurezza
interventi che preservano appunto quelle
funzioni così importante che ripeto non
sono soltanto di carattere fisico ma
anche di carattere cognitivo di
relazione tutte quelle cose che ci
caratterizzano come
come
appartenenti alla razza umana
ed ecco anche ulteriori tecnologie che
ci consentono durante l'intervento di
avere una ray registrazione delle
strutture anatomiche anche dopo i
cambiamenti dovuti all'intervento stesso
quindi per esempio quello di ri
verificare la bontà del di una resezione
è quello di ri registrare sì ce n è
necessario uno una possibilità di
spingersi oltre
nei confronti di una ricezione di una
patologia e questi sono sono cose molto
importanti la tac e la risonanza
magnetica intraoperatoria possono darci
per esempio queste informazioni e questo
e questo è veramente un ulteriore
esempio di quanto è importante
avere come il feedback che queste
informazioni durante un intervento
chirurgico o un intervento
neurochirurgico
questo appunto un esempio in sé positiva
che fa proprio vedere il parco
biotecnologico vedete quanto affollata
può essere una sala operatoria usando
tutte tutte queste tecnologie che ci
consentono solo unicamente le obiettivo
principale quello di preservare la
funzione dei nostri pazienti allo stesso
tempo affrontare la patologia nel
maniera più completa possibile
ecco alcune di queste di questi props di
queste sonde che ci consegnano la
frammentazione e questa è una cosa anche
non non nuova nella ideazione però molto
moderna nella sofisticazione nei modelli
più sofisticati che ci consente di
frammentare tumori intracerebrali
mantenendo ovviamente intatta la
struttura del cerebrale circostante e
questo è un altro esempio di questo
quindi io volevo farvi
soprattutto un discorso su quelle che
sono le
le le tecnologie più avanzate che per
noi in neurochirurgia hanno questa
doppia valenza
e poi volevo parlarvi un pochettino
anche della internazionalizzazione per
me ovviamente è abbastanza naturale
avendo vissuto 33 anni negli stati uniti
27 dei quali spesi alla johns hopkins
university
però per me quello ha un'importanza che
non si limita soltanto alla produzione
scientifica
con la condivisione di
idee di lavori tra diversi centri ma è
anche e ci tengo molto a dirlo è questo
forse il
posto giusto per dirlo visto che questo
avendo condotto da studenti quello della
formazione
e la formazione
internazionale per me ha un importanza
enorme noi
alla facoltà di medicina la cattolica
policlinico gemelli abbiamo delle
relazioni molto intense che sono po
rallentate con il covip però di
specializzandi che vengono prese di noi
ad acquisire e ad acquisire esperienza
che ha esperienza anche su determinati
metodi diversi
altrettanto i nostri specializzandi che
sono in in inesperienza nei centri come
la thomas gibson la northwestern
university e ha per l'appunto alla johns
hopkins university e la mayo clinic a
jackson questo per me avere una
formazione
combinata e uno scambio così è di
importanza fondamentale proprio per il
progresso di quella che è la nostra
disciplina
questo è solo un esempio è così volevo
piano piace è concludere e ci tengo a
farlo è la nostra è una
cifra già dentro una specializzanda
anziana della nonna anziana per così
dire ovviamente del north western
university è venuta da noi e per un
periodo molto prolungato e non è stata
la sola ma ci tengo mostrarla
soprattutto perché perché
dimostra come sono coinvolte come si è
coinvolti in questo aspetto formativo e
qui in di fronte al pantheon eccola con
la cifra ed incolla con la
specializzanda anziana del nostro del
nostro centro ed è stata un'esperienza
ed è tuttora un esperienza in cui questo
scambio fertile consente veramente
l'avanzamento è dal punto di vista
pragmatico anche oltre che a quello
scientifico delle nostre conoscenze e
con questo pensa di lasciarvi vi
ringrazio tutti grazie